And maybe I just don't I don't trust Hutch implicitly the way
that you do. Well, it's like what if what if the evidence is
false? What if you're being used as a puppet? Does that concern
you at all, Hutch? >> I wish there was a way to punish
him like legally more harshly for that because I think that is
deplorable behavior that is does deserve >> It's not that
he just is using somebody. It's that he pretends he is somebody.
He pretends he's a certain guy with certain morals and he's not
even not even close.
You please just explain the situation. Okay, so there is a clipping
Discord that I'm a part of. Okay, I will ask for links to stuff.
Uh I will suggest clips to people. I'll retweet other people's
clips. Right? Basically, they're trying to post like cut up logs
with absent any context as if this is like an evil doxing server.
Destiny wants this to go and float into his greater narrative
that I'm running like a cabal that's been working against him
that hates him and wants to undermine everything he's ever done.
So, but he did this. He said, "Got to say I'm not terribly surprised
to have found this in the leaked snark Discord logs. Folks, this
is online politics. If you're invoking dead family members over
this stuff, you're years overdue for extensive therapy. Delete
your accounts and re-evaluate."
So, they cut off whoever the this was. Now, if someone like that
was doing something like that, I think that there would probably
be a level of value in at least putting the screen name there.
You want the people that own the server to be able to go, "No,
we saw that and we banned them." But this isn't what I do. I've
never been like this. >> I have I think I got sent a a
time stamp of Connor and Doobie arguing about the Snark server.
>> Oh, really? >> I think a lot of people see what's
happening. Yeah, I I try even the um commentary are like latching
on like you Tommy C and they're latching on to this stuff. I
think they even know really that it's they're like they just
you know they know it's an easy attack right now. Yeah, I think
basically a lot of >> you got like you know SCP morons
that are on the the edge of that that you know will sit there
and pretend to be to
>> what I was just saying with Connor with regards to Connor
specifically for me I feel like he sees what's going on and he's
just like not willing to just go yeah I'll never talk to these
people he's like whatever he's going to have the assoc associations
he's going to have he kind of just expects Destiny to tolerate
it the same way >> he expects us expects us to tolerate
his association with Destiny
How long is this doobie thing? I kind of I kind of want to switch
over. I'm sorry, guys. >> Uh, literally so far I mean I
checked the thread that ogre boy has and both statements are
incredibly neutral.
>> Like that's not you guys spamming live and learn is
it someone was spamming Hutch killed his uh killed his sister
over and over. That's even moreed up. You can correct me if I'm
wrong. I've watched this content twice now. But I feel like they
said no no no. We know that the brigade was in the server and
we have evidence that there was no action taken.
>> Yeah, that's what that's what Hutch's uh narrative is.
And it's just an extra >> and and again
>> and so so that's why you're not going to find this big
argument between Orgo and somebody else where he's calling them
out for doing this because they they weren't doing it or at least
they didn't say they were doing it. You know, nobody in the server
was saying they did this. >> I called Hutch a liar over
this. You could easily just blow me out and post the logs.
In fact, I I
um I tried cuz like I said, I wasn't in the server for months,
ever since I got this new account. >> Um so I tried yesterday
to go and find it to see if it was true before I made any comments
about it. Um unfortunately, I think I think it's probably because
it got leaked. I think they archived um the uh the like anything
before the 11th of of May, right? From before whatever got leaked.
It's not deleted. I I think they they still have it. Um, but
you know, it's just not public anymore for me to look it up.
>> So, will you will you walk this back though? Let let's
say that I mean I'll I'll walk it back or I'll say that this
is an evidentiary gap where let's say that they finally release
the manifesto and they spam all the or they show all the evidence
of what they believe to be nefarious behavior in the server and
they omit
evidence of people harassing Hutch via Lib and Learn. Like there's
just no evidence whatsoever that this came from
>> Well, well, I was just going to say I >> there's
no reason for them to like by the way in terms of Destiny saying
he's got to release his manifesto to release those logs. That
doesn't follow at all that he can't that he's wait for his court
case to release the manifesto and that he has to wait for the
manifesto to release the logs. It just none of it follows. It
doesn't make any sense. No, it's obviously just about
him wanting to have a vindication narrative to >> try and
move on from his court case
>> Well, and I think what I think he's hoping is he doesn't
have a vindication narrative, so he's hoping that he can drum
up enough like outrage or anger that he'll get like more things
leaked to him or that he'll like eventually discover something.
I think he's just like delaying as long as he can to try to find
anything. >> Oh yeah, that that's true. Sure. But yeah,
but what what that you know that whatever they have it will be
used for
>> You know.
>> And walk back my >> but let's say the opposite
is true. Let's say that you just haven't seen
>> the evidence that some people server >> like I
I wasn't like like obsessively following the server or anything.
And from my my perception it was just a clipping server where
people would come in talk. I think I had like an argument about
Israel on there once. Uh and most of the is just you know there
are um streamers of these people who are like generally like
on the left side I think of politics. Um it's the impression
I get they follow these streamers. Hassan
um uh [__] uh Pisco Hutch
um uh [__] uh who's this other dude? There's like
a whole like channel dedicated just like clips from different
streamers that they follow, right? And people post their own
streams in there too. Um so not unusual. I think your server
has a channel for posting clips and when there's an argument.
>> Well, Missy, it's like realistically
I think at this point Connor and a bunch of other people should
say, "No, no, no. You have no evidence that these people have
doxed or done anything like that. You're just a total liar, right?"
Like for Destiny has been saying this for over a year now and
has gone after people's tried to dox people over this. Like it's
crazy how long he's just had this like Schroinger's cat, Schroinger's
Doxer thing here where he's saying, "I have proof of this." But
he won't show it to anybody the whole time
>> happening on stream. Um and and your community thinks
it's funny or the other guy's stupid. They'll post a stream like,
"Oh, look, this argument is happening." And they go into chat
and they talk stupid this guy is. Like that's totally normal
for a Discord server. Like it's not that's not harassment. I
think that's totally normal. Um, so I guess I I need to be like
clear about what they think is harassment. Because if harassment
is just, hey, there was a stream happening. People thought I
was stupid. Someone posted that stream in a server where people
thought I was stupid and those people came and called me stupid.
Again, normal behavior for every Twitch stream
>> I think I think where I think where people are going
to argue that it jumps the shark though is going to be the personal
identifiable information in gay ops, right? >> Yeah. And
I just doxing happening. if it did happen. I wasn't aware of
it and I didn't see anything there that would indicate they're
okay with toxin. So I just didn't see it >> well in the
sorry I was just pulling up my my drawing or whatever the so
but but then we >> which of course we need to make this
course this will sort this conversation out in a in an instant.
>> I just pull this my diagram real quick. Let's uh do
we can sort the diagram consult the graph. So, for instance,
like I will not make the claim that seeing Well, hold on. Number
one, that Caiba emailing Rose and her family is indicative of
anybody else's actions besides Caiba.
Um, I'm not I'm not going to make that claim. And then, same
thing,
I should have never let this like narrative take hold. I should
have argued this like extremely extremely strenuously at the
time. It was actually such a mistake to let anybody like I basically
was good faith and was like, "Okay, like you good. I can see
why you think this is." It's like, "No, nope. Nope. He acted
at a higher moral standard with a higher moral character than
anybody else involved here. You like you guys should have been
arguing it the whole time. I feel like it's uh it was a huge
mistake and we will not be making that mistake >> with
the Who's that? I'm I'm Robert Baratheon. Moody Moody Morgan.
Robert Baratheon. uh the cy
like he obviously is the only person who had any concern for
anyone who acted in like any sort of like moral way whatsoever.
Now maybe you could argue you shouldn't do that and I said I
made a rule against him like I just can't have people reaching
out cuz it's it's like um going to eventually go disastrously
right but
>> it's bad precedent and also he did take it too far.
It's just,
you know, this whole idea that you can,
if you're someone online, you can never contact someone relevant
to a case that you know information about. >> I I don't
understand this thinking. Connor was expressing this thinking
earlier in his stream when I watched this earlier. >> It's
they justify it because they would feel bad if they didn't like
do something to prevent harm. So, they're like, "Well, it has
to be wrong for me to ever reach out or care that much." That's
that's how I see it for a lot of
It's because you could just evaluate case by case in my opinion
>> because um yeah I I think honestly like you know if
you're going to do that sort of stuff just
do it on your own time. Don't brag about it online. Don't go
into Discord talking about it. Just like do the right thing and
move on. You know don't get obsessed with it.
>> It sounds It sounds like Cy a little bit
>> I think he basically was like worried this person was
going to disappear and he reached out one time too many. Well,
I say one time like one time to a couple different members of
their family, I >> And like that's too far. >> But
again, everything before that like they always they're like he
sent 30 emails to her. It's like >> yeah, letting her know
like hey here's this platform you should take down. Here's like
this thing people are like trying to look you up on, right? In
a way that she was reciprocating talking back on.
uh Shimu and Neandros openly talking about using PII tools in
order to look up information on TechOne's
potential
they're making the argument, well, we're properly ma motivated
and we're trying to expose a crime. But then often times when
we get into talking about Saiba or any of that kind of stuff,
we kind of get the commentary from people that's like, okay,
well, Destiny's a bad guy, so he kind of deserves it. And and
so that's where I'm saying like
>> oh what
by the way getting her like basically looking her up to get like
her testimony for the Destiny case that's like totally morally
neutral. There's nothing bad about that. And Saaba whether or
not Syboa is involved I still think that happens. So I just I
think that's like a goofy thing to talk about Desty's case with
regards to this. It's whether or not her him contacting her is
bad. And I think the way he did originally was definitely not
bad. It feels like there I know that you you are an individual
sorry I'm not saying like deserves like like deserves what specifically
>> well that's why that's why I would ask individuals so
I would ask Jtock and Queen and I would ask you what does Destiny
deserve does he deserve to have
>> and I'll remind you guys that we're live on a platform
that has a deal and so we cannot answer >> something similar
similar
On a on a real though, it is just like, you know, foolish pun
flest punishment allowable under the law. He should be he should
be held accountable. That's what should
>> You should
>> Yeah. No one's saying you should be swatted or any stupid
like that, right? I mean, unlike he's saying >> it's like
I could hate somebody and think they deserve worse than they
should get for punishment and still be like, "Well, but I have
to follow the law and be a normal human being cuz if I don't
then gives everybody else license to do the same thing, right?"
like morally what he deserves is probably some civil penalty
and in my
I think some some kind of criminal penalty but I wouldn't say
you know >> my opinion is not within the law so we we just
continue >> spammed on Twitter does he deserve to be sued
into the ground does he deserve to be incarcerated
uh what what does he >> I mean I personally I think that
uh this technicality about the the um the date that this law
was made active uh where the revenge thing I think it's a little
bit I wish there there was a way to legally punish him um much
more harshly for sharing revenge or if you don't want to call
it revenge sharing uh news and sex without consent um I wish
there was a way to punish him like legally more harshly for that
cuz I think that is deplorable behavior that is does deserve
punishment um I think he should be punished u for doxing people
for weaponizing weaponizing his community to dox people and harass
people I think those are bad things um I don't think he deserves
deserves to be doxed and swatted and I don't think his deser
his kid deserves to be with or his family uh deserves to be like
harassed or whatever. Um but yeah, it's just I what I would say
he deserves is just uh if we can't if he can't like um be legally
punished for sharing news with indoxing people and uh encouraging
like violence against people, which he's done repeatedly against
like uh like Queen and whatnot, uh then he just deserves the
same criticism any any YouTuber streamer gets. You know, people
making video basically turn him into a local, right? Uh because
he's a he's acting like a crazy person. like that's normal for
YouTube streams, you know, not not a big deal. But I I want to
say something. So, you're waiting for this manifesto that I'm
sure will be released. And my pers my prediction
is that he's going to selectively release things to uh try to
fabricate a narrative just like Hutch did. Um or he's going to
make comments without any evidence just like Hutch did. Um he's
going to lie about the timeline just like he did a little bit
ago that I just showed you. Um but I don't I don't think you
need to wait for it. So Hutch made these claims. Hutch claimed
he had the screenshots to prove what would happened in the server
regarding his dead sister. So just tell him tell him to post
the screenshots publicly and post all the names of the people
that were doing it and post but Hutch won't because he was probably
told not to which is just like hey you're going to make an allegation
publicly and somebody tells you but don't post the evidence right
now. Well it's like what if what if the evidence is false? What
if you're being used as a puppet? Does that concern you at all?
Hutch.
>> I don't I don't think it does. the son of the geek >> post
what Ogre boy said like we know the timeline now is uh January
26 at 7:51 p.m. Ogre boy time. So tell them to post those screenshots
specifically to show what everything that was being said around
that cuz OG boy is claiming that nobody in the in the server
did it. They didn't say they were doing it. Um I think when JO
talked about it, he said that there was like comments about Hush
being like a a bald who couldn't follow the conversation or something
like around that. Like that's what they were talking about
watching the stream. Yeah. Totally normal. Um but none of them
were with a sister. None of them said they did it. So there was
no argument about that. That that is something that I'm gonna
hold you to.
>> That is something that I'm gonna hold you to though
where I'm gonna, you know, in a month or two if they do have
that evidence, I'm going to be like, "Hey, Doobie, how do you
feel now that we have updated evidence that there actually was
people in the server who were participating in the >> snarking
of his dead sister?" >> Yeah, I would say it's wrong to
do. It's [__] up behavior. Again, I can't sign on
to everything that was ever said in any Discord server that I'm
in, right? Like, so I'm your server. I'm sure people say [__]
in there that I disagree with all the time. uh you know I'm in
my server I I know people say crazy [__] there all
the time so like yeah it's I >> the argument is going to
be though it is going to be guilt by association
um so
the if you so so for instance like you and I both dealt with
the stochastic rhetoric
wars of 2019 to 2022
where effectively the community that you attract the community
that you police and by the way you know Destiny actually used
to be super aggressive about this uh where he would say, "No,
no, no, no. As a creator,
um if you are permissive of misogynist behavior or racist behavior
in a non-joking way or if you're permissive of XYZ ABC behavior."
>> Oh, he's got a whole hive of What the are you talking
about, Connor? Like, shut up. Shut the [__] up, man.
>> I think he's saying Destiny used to be big on this,
but not anymore.
>> Destiny was never big on this. Destiny may be figned
being big on this for like 6 months during the Red Pill arc.
Off on that one, too. >> I know cuz guess what? I used
to be in that chat making misogynist comments all the time. All
right. I I literally could say for sure absolutely not. >> Then,
you know, you're going to cultivate that kind of community. And
I feel like that's just descriptively true. So, one of the things
that they're going to fall back on argumentatively, and I'll
just give you a preview of the fact that I'm going to agree with
it, is the fact that if you have a server where people are using
docs tools openly, no criticism, uh if, and I'm saying if because
I haven't seen this evidence, right? But if there's a server
where they're doing they're boosting tweets, they're boosting
tweets specifically that are meant to with other creators. Uh
which I have seen evidence for then and I J >> wait meant
to with other creators like does he mean clips from our streams?
Like I >> I clips from their streams. I don't think it
matters either way. But the you know what what is with if it's
you know if it's not a lie if it's not malicious then what what's
the argument there >> is a genuine criticism
>> has admitted to and then if we see evidence and this
hasn't been established but let's say that we see evidence that
there were two or three people who were in the server and they're
like yeah lol it was me I was with Hutch you know his dead sister
who gives a [__] let's I think said uh let let's
turn Hutch's sister into a chair or something like as a joke,
right? Then yeah, I didn't say whoa whoa. That's not my joke.
Hello. >> I definitely I heard Queen say that on the stream
like two days ago. >> TV reviews chair at my hutch sister
desk. I think you said something like >> I I did say I
I Well, I did I did repeat what said, but that's not my joke,
is it? Let's not give me credit. >> Reviews brother chair.
Yeah, brother chair. Brother chair. My bad. Consists of logs
of me being misogynist.
>> Sure, that's legal. Like I'm I'm not going to sue you,
but at the same time I'm going to view that as like wildly antisocialed
up behavior and I'm going to associate correlated negative antisocial
behavior.
The best example and listen, I don't necessarily have like a
war to fight with forethought or anything anymore. Okay. But
like all you need to know about Destiny's like real long-term
connect commitment to fighting misogyny in DGG was basically
when forth when he was confronted on forethought telling Kelly
Jean that she was going to end up having to a dog for her only
fans cuz she was like >> an unlovable loser that Destiny
was like you know what Kelly Gene exception I I'm not even going
to try to not even try to police this Kelly Gene exception
with your community because of the stochcasticness of it. Now,
if you want to say DGG does the same [__] I'm going
to be like, "Yeah, there's schizophrenic elements of DGG that
do do the same and it's up and they shouldn't be doing it and
Destiny shouldn't be encouraging
>> Sure. But, so one, uh, again, I don't know every single
thing about said in that server. When I looked at it, um, which
wasn't often, it was just clips, people talking,
people arguing about things, uh, people hanging out in chat,
watching streams or watching like movies or whatever or playing
video games. Not not this was not like a if if I think like organized,
uh, channel or server dedicated to with somebody. I think uh,
what Dan Sultman had in Destiny server dedicated to with Assan
for like months. It's like a channel specifically dedicated to
this where they were like they had like templates for emails
he could spam to his advertisers and they were trying to find
his family members openly, right? Like that was that was existed
in the server for months. That's what I think when I say oh this
is a community dedicated to harassing somebody or with somebody.
That is not what this is. This is just >> can I engage
in the same
which uh >> so so just real quick do you remember Twitch
poll uh that >> that's obviously true. I want to hear Connor's
rebuttal of this >> which discord server that was around
like forever ago. Uh, I mean, was it the one I only knew about
your server. I only knew about the politics server. I didn't
know about a specific Twitch pull >> It was a very small
server that was made forever ago with like Samantha Savage and
uh, >> yeah, Samantha Banana. She's she's one of my favorite
skits, too. >> Yeah, she's cool. Um, and it was just like
a bunch of streamers on the server and like small streamers and
they would post clips and their community would come and post
different clips and post their streams and they would talk about
it and if there's a stream happening they would post it there
so people would go and and watch the stream and argue about it
like that. That's what kind of what this is and I understand
it's uh primarily organized around people they dislike. Um, so
if uh
I h
it's got like a hater spirit to it, but like I I do think there's
some positive elements to it as well. Like like there's community.
There's there's like an actual drive and a direction. People
like the political messaging in a lot of cases. It's it's not
all hate. I would say there's a hater element for sure. possibly
possibly a majority hater element, but it's not like it's like
99% hate. I would not say that. >> Uh Hutch says something
stupid. Very likely there's gonna be a clip of it in there and
people are going to touch about it, right? Which is again totally
normal. In every server, uh if some if Hassan says something
stupid, it pops up in your server and people again normal. >> So
I I just don't think this is >> normal for this space.
I want to amend.
So, so, so for instance, like I I you know, I'll reference my
drawing again. Uh, hate watching Twitch poll endlessly.
saw Twitter like skitso Discord community sners and skitso DG.
Uh, this is kind of weird. Oh my god. Let people enjoy things.
Uh, uh, this
Well, that that picture helped. Now I get it. Thank you, Connor.
Now I get it. >> So, what I'm agreeing to is I don't think
this is normal
for normal people. I think this is normal quote unquote for our
space. But I want to I want to drag you back to a statement about
Dan Saltman. Can I real quick?
>> So you said Dan created a specific Hassan hate discord
and did PII gay ops against Hassan is trying to ruin his career
with his advertisers with Twitch, etc., etc. >> Oh, this
server thing I'm talking about. I know there's another Discord
server, but that was like where they were like posting his family.
Let's just say Dan Salman's gone out of his way to with Assan's
career. Is that accurate enough?
>> Okay. So, what Dan said, which I think is going to he
would fall back to argumentatively and I would potentially be
sympathetic to is that Hassan deserves it, right? Sweep for Hezbollah,
swept for Hamas, always does apologia for jihadist organizations
and theocratic regimes worldwide. Hates the American Empire.
What's America to fall apart? uh m uh
okay it's literally everybody's argument
he analogizes
Zionism to Nazism
and then he's also said in the past that Nazis deser they shouldn't
even be or Zionists shouldn't even be employed as your local
dog walker they or dog catcher they should actually be like socially
ostracized and banned from humanity so Dan can say hey um I am
going out on my way to with this guy's social media career, but
I don't think I've ever Well, at least not recently. I don't
think I've ever heard Dan say he's not doing it >> right.
He just says that he's doing it and then he does it. >> Yeah.
That's why
>> this isn't a pass or even a positive thing. It's like
a totally neutral
It's not It doesn't make you better that you say you do the thing
you're doing. Doesn't make you better. I'm sorry. It
>> I brought it up. What I'm telling you is that when I
think of obsessively trying to somebody's career, that's what
I think of, right? I've never seen anything in that server or
in JO server that comes even close to what Dan was doing there
openly on Destiny's main Discord server and in like the side
servers that he had. No, nowhere even close. Right. So, I agree
that Dan would say, "Yeah, I'm just doing because Focus is on."
I agree. I I kind of respect that actually. But, uh, what I'm
telling you is that I I've never seen anything even close to
that. And and if that's acceptable, I don't think it is. If that's
acceptable to you people, then I don't understand why you'd have
an issue with what was happening in the server or in JSON server
or in any of these other server. Now, to be clear, again, I don't
know everything that was happening there. So, it could be that
there there was like some secret doxing channel that I just didn't
see or or they had like a big conversation about doxing somebody
that I I just didn't see. Totally possible, right? I don't know
everything happens in the Discord server, but I just have not
seen any of it. I've never seen anybody supporting it. I just
haven't. So, >> okay then I will uh join
watch for 3 minutes. E watch for 3 minutes. What is this? They'll
be on multiple accounts. You saw the phrase gay ops, you know.
Um and that I don't like to say what it is. You should just ask
them and then we'll see in a month where they still stand, right?
Do you support creating astroturfed accounts to go into counterpoint
stream? They do that. To go into pisco stream, they do that.
To go into touch stream, they do that. to either pretend to be
innocent third parties. They do that. Or to pretend to be unhinched
DJs. They do that when >> That's evidenced by the logs,
right? >> Yes. And then on that and then on top of that,
when you have them mass reporting >> the thing is I would
generally discourage like making accounts to pretend to be other
people. But I don't see that as like this huge crime, you know?
Like I I I would discourage that. I don't want people doing that.
It looks stupid. It makes you look mad.
But like is that what what is the uh what's the what's the criticism
there really? I I don't really understand. But yeah, some chatters
do like that. >> I mean, I've I've definitely laughed at
the idea of Kathy doing it, but it's mostly because when Kathy
does it, he >> like the idea Sorry, I will just laugh at
this because it was funny to me. >> Like the idea of Stardust
engaging with Kathy as one of the three chatters that are in
her chat, and she probably knows that Gunbox is like not a real
fan of
She probably has a good idea, right? But it's like Kathy is just
like talking to Stardust and Stardust is like engaging back because
it's the only chatter there like that. I'm sorry that's funny.
And maybe you'd say that's encouraging to say it's funny,
but
I don't know. Like I I guess I like I discourage it. I would
discourage doing like what I would refer to as like a chatter
gay op. Like if you're going to go and say I'm a DJer and I think
this I think that's stupid. I don't I don't want people doing
that. >> Yeah. But but would you like is that something
you're supposed to moderate around? I if I saying something you're
supposed to moderate I don't
why am I supposed to moderate that? Why am I supposed to give
a someone's doing that >> The other thing is is like Kathy
does it to us.
>> Like it's also it's like sort of a funny thing that
we all know he does. He's like a character. I don't know. Like
I >> his first couple months of showing up, it was like,
you know, people people would get one guy by Cathy and then drag
drag whoever it was in and then it'd come in and be doing an
Indian accent. You'd look stupid and it's like, oh my
>> The one where he calls into peace go straight and he's
like, is it him in >> I'm outside. I'm outside.
>> It's so funny, man. Uh it's like it's like a whole bit.
I don't know. whatever.
Yeah. I don't know if you moderate around it or whatever. It's
I'd say if you found examples of him doing like really negative,
but it's mostly like from what I've seen, it's mostly
>> I don't you know I banned Kathy because of this stupid
lone tweet he made cuz it's just like annoying when I'm trying
to talk to someone. But it's not because I don't think I should
moderate off platform behavior like ever. I don't think I've
ever got an obligation to do that really.
I I moderate my communities. That's That's just my job, right?
I I thought, is that really that crazy?
>> I mean, in this case, I don't know exactly what Kathy
would say. Like, if Kathy's pushing his own screenshots into
Snark Left and we're all like laughing at it, then that is involving
that community. You know what I mean?
>> But it's not my Discord. I don't I'm not a mod there.
It's not It's my responsibility.
Like, like I said, if I had a good idea that the Hutch thing
was Kathy or someone else from that Discord, I would want them
gone. I not even like probably on on moral grounds, but I wouldn't
make that argument in that Discord because I don't think most
people like think that way. Like I I would make it just like
this. >> I feel like you just make a rod for your own back
saying that like I don't I just don't give a to moderate what
every crazy chatter is saying in every other chat. I don't I
just don't care.
Uh, I I would say like I dislike it. That's just But it's again
a personal preference. Like it feels like a liability. That would
be what I'd say.
But again, I I don't control that Discord and I might have a
say like I might have a voice there, but that would just be my
argument and then I would let other people decide. There's lots
of times I've wanted to ban people from >> It's your argument
and the natural, you know, sort of like authority that comes
with being a a bigger streamer in an area with either small streamers
or chatters. It's like but it's like that you can't be expected
to go around throwing your weight around to get changed in every
Discord server you're in. Like that's
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Exactly. It's like hey if you are
running the server, someone's running the server and you it's
like I'll give you my argument why I think this right and then
you can make your
I'll I'll participate and not try to like put too much influence
into it how I feel about it. Anyway
anyway back to the content. uh when you have them uh a logging
or doxing people in a way that you can reach out and find other
people in their lives to communicate with. They do that, right?
The worst of that
or doxing people so you can find other people in their lives
to communicate with. They do that.
That's a that's a lot further than what I thought. Oh, he's talking
about Cyba. Well, yeah. I to be fair, he like lied about Cyba
being in there. Cyba's never been in there. Never seen cyber
in there, but I didn't check it for 3 months. So, >> yeah.
Yeah. >> Let me uh let me just ask you a question because
obviously this is the kind of evidence that I would like by the
way. Uh not that it's not available. I just haven't had >> Yeah.
He Well, he wants to Missy, what that is right there is that's
him trying to join the idea of my Discord and and the Snarkle
left discord as the same group of people or the same Yeah. Right.
He wants those tied together because then he can have some reason
to blame my discord and my community while this discord could
have like could have potentially been something engaging in worse
behavior which I don't think they've got any evidence of that
at all. Right. I think he's trying to do the like you know queen
was saying the two years it was all to tie this together as one
narrative but I think they sort of overestimated what they had
and peace goes well
certainly was he was on that for a little bit.
Okay, back to the DB combo. >> The the chorus
of people,
>> Assassan Putin and John Fabro are involved, too. And
Kyle Kolinsky. Don't forget Kyle. >> You know, Destiny
obviously writes his manifestos at his own pace andor has co-writers
that write them at >> You don't need it. >> You don't
need the manifesto. You just >> Well, no. That's what I'm
saying. I want I want all I want all the logs.
>> They They made They made a plan today to post it. should
be sorry. Folks right now should be pressuring Hutch to prove
that Ogre is a full and that actually
defend defend my lady's honor.
>> Let let me defend Hutch's honor real
>> You you just you just trust him implicitly for some
reason when he >> Yeah. He has a You got You guys see a
bald head in a in a blank
>> SSRI stare. >> Oh my god. And I see a beautiful
bald
>> and I see a beautiful, you know,
>> detached chair. >> And so, yeah, I trust him.
>> let's go. >> So, but hold on. Hold on with Hutch.
I think that it has been claimed that there is evidence that
this server participated in the spamming of his dead sister.
Uh, so that's one of the things that I would want to uh pressure
Destiny and um Hutch to release is one release all the logs because
we should be able to evaluate the evidence by ourselves, but
then two uh there's been a specific claim that this server was
responsible for the
dead sister gay op. Uh, you either need to resend that claim
or you need to evidence. >> It's not a gay up spammy chation.
>> It's not evening if people don't tell you tell someone
to do it. It's like
some spamming. That's all it is. >> Yeah. Like I wouldn't
say like if if basically somebody decided to do that and it eventually
gets tied back to somebody from the server. Like if we had no
way of knowing it if people cuz I know people asked. People were
like, "Hey, I don't want I want to be a part of like that." Like,
"Fuck off." People didn't like it and people asked and a bunch
of people went, "No, no, no, no, no. Absolutely not."
>> your folks right now should be to pressure him to do
cuz right now um >> Oh, I that all that to say is if it's
some acting on their own, it's not about the character of the
server. >> especially when it's like pretty verifiably
outside the character of the server. Not that people wouldn't
joke in the server. I'm saying it's just it's a little weird
to go to like spam chats. And as much as as much as Kathy Kathy's
like a a skits or whatever and people will like say he makes
accounts and he goes to other I haven't seen him like go and
just spam like the most offensive like he's normally trying to
do
>> like it's sort of outside of the behavior and that is
not outside of the behavior of other like YouTube skits chatters
that I've seen in different
It's like sort of outside of the Kathy behavior though. It's
just and not saying it couldn't be or something but I I just
haven't seen it from him.
So anyway, >> yeah, and I would say your folks right now
should be to pressure him to do because right now um Jay Sulkman,
they're all on Ogrebo's side because Og Boy has these screenshots,
right? Where we can prove like just outright that he did say
what he what Hutch said he didn't say. So we So unless Hutch
has any evidence, Hutch is lying. But but I'm not going to go
so far as to say that it's lying because the the color the color
of >> Hutch is lying or he is like a emotional who is making
an accusation that's going to be used to essentially again create
a permission structure manufactured consent for some negative
actions and it needs to be evaluated now before the bad things
happen.
I had somebody in my chat earlier tonight saying they were calling
the cops on me. Otter, if you could try to pressure people into
presenting some evidence for the that's being said, I would appreciate
it. Okay, time is running out.
>> Time is running out. >> The ogre boy. So maybe
I need to watch the ogre boy.
>> Can Can I just get Can I get a commitment from Connor
that when my obituary is published that he'll eventually go,
"Hey, I need that evidence now."
Maybe then at least
>> thank you. Thank you. Oh, the thing is that Destiny's
perspective is that he he was helping Swam. So,
I I say over your lowering coffin
>> without Hutch's coloring of his statement. Maybe that
would be the the most objective way to do it. >> But the
but the ogre boy, it sounds like ogre boy.
>> Oh, at the end of the clip I sent, Dusty shows him some
supposed evidence off screen. I'm going to say that that's me
basically saying here's how you report Destiny for doxing.
That's probably like the thing. I'd say that's probably the again
I that's me doing that. Okay. So, >> like I said, I think
that must be it can't be that anything that bad because um like
I spoke to Connor. He said, "I haven't seen anything that couldn't
be resolved by calling you the fa about both of us."
>> Is that I'm just telling you how it sounds. It sounds
like Ogre Boy is at the gym. He sees somebody spamming Hutch's
dead sister in the chat. He goes, "Oh, everybody's blaming me."
He DMs Pisco and he says, "Hey, bro. Just let you know that's
not me." He goes to the Discord and he says, "Hey, is anybody
doing this? I'm getting blamed for it." That's not a like impugning
of anybody doing it. That that that's not even a negative statement.
Like like he's not calling it. He's literally
So this is why I said that you need to watch the statement again
because when Ogre boy says that he went to the discord server
and asked if if they were doing this or said it's not you guys
doing this is it Hutch said that that was a lie. So he so not
even oh he ogre was claiming he came in and yelled at people
and Hutch was saying that is a lie. He's saying that Ogreway
didn't even go in and ask if it was them doing it right. So so
that
>> fantastic stuff Connor. >> Yes I would encourage
you to watch it again. He decided to go on your
>> How How did you even do this? >> I'm muted right
now and uh over my
>> chat, so I need to unmute. Um I would need to see that
specific clip of him saying like no, Ogre Boy never went into
the server in order to challenge people. And I don't think it
would be never went into the server. I think the the the object
in question would be too >> I what I want to know is why
is the screenshot they're presenting there why is that cropped
without the time stamp? You know what I mean? Like that's the
screenshot Hutch is presenting there is cropped without the the
time stamp. That feels incredibly intentional to me, doesn't
it? It just feels so bizarre that they're going to crop that
without the time stamp and say look look at this. Look at this
terrible terrible thing. I do agree that it would be like a lone
actor because there just broadly isn't consensus to go after
like somebody publicly for that kind of thing to like attack
them in that way. You know what I mean? So, I do think it seems
like a lone agent, but I'd still like to know who it was so be
like,
>> what are you doing?"
>> Uh, the original link it
someone was spamming Hutch killed his sister over and over again
and people were blaming me. Two dead reactions. That's a very
neutral statement. And then that's not you guys spamming live
and learn, is it? Once again, that's like a neutral statement.
He's not he's not saying that. And and by the way, by the way,
Ogre Boy said that he said that better not be any of you.
So, is Ogre boy hyperbolizing his pos? >> Yes, those are
the logs he's presenting position in order to look better optically
or is >> probably not remembering precisely what he said.
>> Is he um exaggerating? Well, hold on. No, no, no. That's
exactly what he's doing. I don't even know why I'm pretending
to entertain this.
>> He probably felt that way and then he came into a space
that he was like not had not been in for that long, right? And
he probably didn't know how to be like that aggressive and so
he's probably feeling that way. There better not be any of you
guys. >> Also, it's like, you know, what you're supposed
to he doesn't know that it's anyone in there doing it and he's
supposed to watch Spur out the moment it happens. Assume it's
someone in there.
>> Like this is obviously an equivalent statement, right?
Hey, this isn't you guys, right? This isn't you guys, right?
It's like they're the same thing. I don't know. To call him a
liar over this is itself a lie in my opinion. Say you're a liar
cuz you >> cuz you slightly hyperbolize this. >> He's
exaggerating the way that he called out the server in order to
look like he doesn't want anything to do with these gay ops.
>> but that's not what he said. There there's no moral
indignation in these two screenshots.
I think it's a misreading. So Urggo isn't saying, my understanding
is that he went in there and yelled at them. What he's saying
is that if it was them, he would go in there and yell at them
because he thinks it's up and even if he's new there, he he still
thinks it's wrong, so he would go in there and yell at them.
And he's saying that he he's so outraged by that behavior that
he was being accused of that if it were them, he'd be angry,
right? And he he yell at them. So this and uh and uh what um
Hutch is saying is that he never even asked in the server if
it if it was them. So >> okay then then then I I would
have to >> we should just pressure Hush today to release
the screenshots he claims he has that will show the people posting
about his death sister at that time with Ogre boy there aware
that it's happening and like because otherwise Hutch is just
just lying. Okay, I buy into
>> I buy into
in order to for me to claim that somebody is a liar. Maybe I
have a higher threshold.
I can't this could to me a misunderstanding of the statement.
So for instance, >> the misunderstanding can be cleared
up by one of the parties.
Should be pushing for the misunderstanding to be cleared up.
that Ogre Boy saying
um and they were banned cuz somebody's spamming that in my chat
right now. JTO's contention
is saying that Ogre Boy didn't mean that the people who were
harassing uh Hutch and Libid Learns chat were banned from the
Starker
>> Oh no. My contention is that anybody who' said that
Hutch's made a joke about Hutch's dead sister in that server
wouldn't be banned for it. That's my contention. He was saying
that they were pretty close to instantaneously banned from the
Lib and Learn chat, but based off of the words,
>> I could understand how Hutch would infer that he said
that they were banned from the server. So, that to me isn't Hutch
going like, "Oh, yeah. Uh, I'm I don't have any evidence for
these claims, but I'm going to claim that I have the evidence
for the claims, and I'm going to exaggerate the situation so
people are are uh sympathetic to me." That to me literally could
be explained by a misunderstanding of the words happening. So
for me to call Hutch a liar, I would >> fine. So
if you want to hold off on calling him a liar right now and maybe
I just don't I don't trust Hutch implicitly the way that you
do. >> Yeah, his SSRI stand bald head rub you wrong. I
got it. >> Um what I would just encourage everybody to
do is tell Hush to just post the logs that he has about this
specific interaction with the people there that were that were
doing it. That can happen today. Has nothing to do with the manifesto.
So there's no reason to wait. And that would prove immediately
that that ogre boy is lying and nobody should trust him. That
that JTO is lying and nobody should trust him because JCO, if
I remember correctly, he also said that he looked at the logs,
right? And it wasn't there. So that would prove immediately that
it's all a lie. They're all they're all full of how could you
do that right now and it just imploded. >> Um I said I
couldn't see that in the logs, but I don't know like when that
was deleted, if that was deleted. I what I was talking about
with the logs was I could see that multiple people were saying
no no that's not us that's not us that's not us nobody took nobody
took responsibility for it nothing like that >> yeah so
>> but I but I think Ogre boy made a uh as much as I dislike
the guy I find him to truly be one of the least pleasant people
on the internet uh I think he did make a good point the reason
why they're not releasing all the logs right now uh this is I'm
trying to quote him almost directly is he's saying like they
could release all the logs call everybody in the server gay and
move on. But they want to drip feed this in order to maximize
the content and the drama so they can villainize everybody who's
in the server without actually evidencing their claims or criticisms.
And I think that's just true. Um I I think they are I think they
are milking it. >> Yeah, I agree. I think they're they're
uh building this narrative so they can lie uh hyperboise, exaggerate,
and and people will just believe it because it sounds right to
them. Yeah, but I told I told Queen this the other day. >> Sorry.
Go ahead.
>> Mr. White Hut should be encouraged not to post all the
logs but the logs about this specific interaction that he >> all
cop redemption arc. No, no. I feel like Connor is about to make
the point that like actually if you have nothing to hide, you
have nothing to fear. So you should just publish everything.
It's like how about the people making the allegation? The way
every other system works in the entire world, the people making
the allegation post the actually alleging. How about that? claims
Ogre Boy is lying about. >> If he has this, he can prove
that Ogre is full of right now and just destroy his reputation.
Destroy Jay Sock's reputation right now. There's no reason to
wait for anything else. He doesn't need to release all the logs.
Just this specific thing. >> Yeah, that's all he needs
to do. >> But he he he doesn't want to up Destiny
sweating the
>> So instead of getting the truth, instead of like not
letting this Paul the hangover, you just want to let Desi run
his stupid. Okay. also like sweating the snarkers. Like this
is energized people. People are active. People are interested,
engaged.
So you can say people sweat. I'm sure some people are panicking
at some point. They don't don't know what they've said. They
can't check their logs or
but I mean I feel like everything's chill at least for most content
creators
>> for us. Yeah.
>> Next two months and then releasing a manifesto that
gets 20,000 live, you >> Yeah. Yeah, but you you know that's
a stupid that's a stupid position. So him >> it's a stupid
position politically and
>> you're just Connor just wants him to win which is unfortunate
but like do you know what I mean? Like that's the only thing.
It's just prioritizing destiny winning with impact on his manifesto
in two months or however many months we're waiting for his court
case. In the meantime I've got people spamming PII for people
in my community in Hutch's chat. I've got people in my chat saying
they're calling the cops. Okay. I would I would like some resolution
on some of these things, Connor, because I feel like things are
getting really heated.
>> But hey, I'll >> Connor does say that Destiny's
going scorched earth and is not shown the evidence to justify
it.
>> He does say that.
>> So, I mean, he does say it's wrong. He does say it's
wrong. >> Well, there's some coralaries of that. It's like
people should not be politically tied to this person. this person
is a like duplicitous
I don't know borderline evil person who's only self-interested
like some other consequences of this that you should admit you
know what I mean >> I think Connor sees it as just like
he's just like you know it's a transactional thing where he's
using Destiny and Destiny uses him you know
>> okay
question about that >> that's my my vibe from Connor basically
sees as transactional and that you know it's a it's a he'll continue
associating with Destiny cuz he thinks that's good
>> that's useful to him. >> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah.
>> So, I have crazy hate for that. I'm not like crazy upset
about that. >> Moral cleansing. Well, I just I don't want
these people to ever act like they're like acting based on morals
>> It's a smart position if you want money >> in
general. No, it's not. It's okay. >> Don't you love money,
Doobie? I for one know that you love money. >> It's It
doesn't make any sense, Connor. So for Hutch, it would make more
sense to pull some of that engagement away right now because
it exists and pull it to his stream for the exposure stream where
he shows that Ogre Boy is full of and JC was lying and didn't
blow the entire thing himself. There's no reason for him to give
that to Destiny. So he could do that right now. He just post
the the Ogre by interaction. >> It'd be very simple. He'd
make money doing it. DJ would come to support him. Be all very
like have he'd get a victory over over the Snarkers. It'd be
very good for him. Mhm. >> There's no reason not to do
that right >> Did you see DJ's doing a call to action to
call the Canadian CIA on you? CSIS, not even your FBI equivalent.
Uh, no, but I mean, people were coming in my chat and doing it.
So, I assume something like that was happening.
>> Kind of crazy, but what can you do? >> But but
and I want to say really quickly, um, >> by what can you
do? I mean,
>> I don't know, dude. Skittles is going to be skits, man.
>> Sort of. So people in chat have been saying that I justified
um a logging uh Destiny's son
which is ridiculous.
Um so and I think one of them said that I just like the standard
the difference in standards here like Dub saying you completely
destroy the reputation. It's like okay if you show these guys
lying one time they'll completely you'll completely destroy the
reputation. Now let's get to lie 9,000. Provable lie 9,000 from
Destiny and we'll analyze that.
Like that's that's the thing is Trump. Connor says he doesn't
like Trump. Connor says he moves over to the center, maybe even
center left and canvases with Democrats because he hates Trump.
And his favorite guy on earth is just liberal Trump.
It makes no [__] Like it's so that's my problem with
Connor is he just obviously doesn't hold any of the standards
or morals he claims to have. It's very frustrating to listen
to.
It's not It's not that he just is using somebody. It's that he
pretends he is somebody. He pretends he's a certain guy with
certain morals and he's not. Even not even close. It's very frustrating
to me to let that go. Just shut up about being a good person.
Shut up about caring about things. Just say you're here to make
money. Like me. I say I'm here to make money. Don't pretend you
care about morals. Don't care about any of that. Don't pretend
you care about this when it's obvious you go back on everything
you say all the time. >> That I did um a log Destiny Center
that I do do that to like go after his employers when he's like
awake like a an adult.
Um, so total total nonsense to be clear. I don't agree with that.
I don't think it's justified. I didn't do it. There's a guy on
Twitter that W's speaking to. I think it was like a month uh
like a little over a month ago.
Um who said that he was going to a Destiny's son and then when
he gets like all the crazy that Destiny's been saying on Twitter
like the old right stuff.
>> Um he's going to track it all and then when he gets
old enough to get a job he's going to send it to his employer
to like him. I I think that's wrong. I don't think anybody should
ever do this. And what I said to Wick because Wick had the guy
on and they were talking about it, right?
What I said to Wick is that uh if Destiny wants to build this
tit fortat um world where you can do where he can put people's
families at risk um then there's no reason that they can't put
his family at risk. So if that's what he wants to do, he's creating
the permission structure to justify that. I don't think any of
us should. I don't think he should do that. I don't think they
should do that. Nobody should do that. But that's what he's been
doing to other people for like over a year now. So I have a family.
I have a wife. I have a son. I have 764 people. Adam Waffen people
people 098 people been trying to find years that made very violent
threats at me for years that I've gotten arrested repeatedly
for years. And he's he's trying to dox me. He's encouraging people
to dox me. That puts my family at risk. >> So I think I'd
be totally justified in with him in very severe ways actually
that that are go far beyond legal. But I'm not going to do that
because I don't like that world. Right. So if you know and I'm
I'm on the sidelines what people do with that back to him. >> I'm
on the sidelines and everybody hates this because it's too boring.
But uh I think some of y'all need Jesus. And what I mean by that
is like
>> this is what I'm talking about. Quan, I'm sorry. It's
like so
literally just understand the scripture of like turning the other
cheek. Somebody hits you. Somebody hits you in the face, you
turn the other cheek. Um, and then somebody asks you for your
cloak, you give them your jacket, too. Somebody asks you to walk
one mile with them, you walk two miles with them. And so the
the whole point of that attitude is to actually I just heard
all I'm asking is if you're going to say this, stop sucking Satan's.
Okay, that's all that's literally it. That's like the only bar
I have. Don't
>> don't pretend you care about this stuff. Don't you have
morals? And then say like this and then just be like, but also
I'm going to wait for Destiny. I'm going to wait until it's 2
years since Destiny started saying you're a doctor. Then I'll
then I'll ask them for some evidence. Then I'll get some evidence.
Then I'll actually make a stand on this. >> This recently
is when somebody hits you in the face, they're demeaning you,
right? When they hit you again and you don't have a response,
you're effectively accepting the fact that or you're you're saying,
"No, I'm on your level. Probably I'm better than you because
your hit doesn't even do anything to me." >> So So that's
the that's kind of the point of turning the other cheek. Now,
I do understand that there comes a time where especially like,
you know, cuz we're not Christ. Um, there's a time where it's
like you can't just take hits to the face anymore. You have to
do something. Uh, but I do think that DGG, and I've criticized
them, and I think you've heard me criticize them in this, they
say they're doing tit fortat, but they're doing barbarian retributive
violence. So they see that Morau and not Morau, excuse me. They
see that uh Shimu and Nicandros are engaged in PII gay ops on
a server and they're saying, "Oh, okay. Well, they've engaged
in doxing. We don't care about the context of it. So, we're going
to just rape everyone
like like because Queean and Jtock hate on the DGG community
and hate on Destiny so much. We're going to use this as a war
pretext to Jtock
Doobie and anybody who's critic uh criticizing us and that's
effectively barbarian retributive violence. And I think that's
descriptively true.
Like do you do you think that um and I know you're going to say
no to this, but I'm asking your chat really um like do they think
it would be reasonable or justified for Hassan to uh to dox all
of them to encourage this community to find every single one
of them with their families because that is what they are doing.
They they should talk Asan constantly. They criticize him whenever
he does dumb. This is earlier today. um whenever you guys stream
about Hassan, people in chat saying he's a monster, evil communist
or whatever the So if and
openly trying to ruin this guy's career, encouraging people to
get him like a to report him, get him off Twitch, get him off
YouTube, whatever. So like if that justifies
uh doxing people and trying to like uh find their family and
with them, then all of them have justified they've just justified
doing that to themselves. Yeah. If I were to just said in chat
that uh DGG is justified in everything, destiny means no rules.
Well, found runner, you have a wife and kids. What you're justifying
there is me or somebody else finding your family and with your
children. I don't think you actually want to live in that world.
I I get this quote to be as you on the internet and say dumbit
like that. That is not okay. So So I I just I'm encouraging you
just take a step back, just think about what you're saying and
what you're encouraging and what you're like condoning uh to
be done to you even if you don't give a [__] if it's
done to other people. >> No, no, no. And and I think that
u I know a lot of people are critical of you in chat or whatever,
but I think that if they were to take anything away,
let's take a step back. Let's think about the world that we're
creating. Let's think about the behaviors that we're endorsing
and let's uh come up with like rules of the game that doesn't
result in everybody getting raped. >> Thanks for talking.
Well, thanks for coming on and uh I you know, as much as we beef
about Israel Palestine sometimes, I I hope that you don't get
>> Yeah, you're so wrong about everything and your world
view makes a world worse. Okay, [__] you. But I love
you. Bye-bye. >> Okay. I love you, too. Bye.
>> Oh, should point out that Desi's like a disingenuous
liar. Like I I That's what I think he doesn't do. He's like,
you shouldn't like Desessie lies about everything all the time.
Yes, Desi's a consistent liar. That's that's just shown that
Desty's a consistent liar.
And I think not saying that it feels like you don't have to cut
him off, but you should be able to accurately like this is your
standard as well, Queen. If he he's not saying Dan's a doxer,
he's not like ribbing Dan for doxing. He is he is quite literally
like not saying the thing, which is Desi is a liar. He's a totally
unreliable narrator. You shouldn't trust anything he says. Which
I think is just objectively true at this
And it's rough.
And Destiny could change that opinion by showing Connor the the
evidence he has for the claims he's made,
but it just isn't happening. It's never happening.
Okay. All right. Okay. All right.
See here. We got anything funny at the end of this combo
going on here. Uh, by the way, I'm pretty sure Hutch is I I feel
like I'm pretty confident Hutch is a liar.
Like total liar. Obvious liar.